i think of course i think there's always
going to be
someone better than the person you're
with
but can that person come and
take you from your man that's not always
the case
so i can give you an example of when i
was in a relationship
i had a huge crush on this guy that i've
known
for a very long time longer than i knew
the guy i was in a relationship with and
whenever i would see him which wouldn't
be
that often i'd probably see him like
once a year
is that already a problem what
like your partner having a crush on
someone like a huge crush on them
and then seeing them semi-regularly
like let's say if my girl would have a
crush on someone else and she has a
crush on that person and she sees them
regularly yeah yeah
there's nothing i could do listen i'm a
fatalist
i told you that already there's nothing
i can do
right i don't have that power i don't
want to control people like
no you stay home you don't i don't want
to i want to say that
mate i want to say that i want to save
the relationships i want this person to
be listen
you are you're a grown ass person
you want to see that person make your
decisions that's
it there's nothing i could do yeah it's
like i'm at the point where i'm not like
i'm not
is there a pr is it a problem
maybe maybe it you know what but that's
their response you know what it
it could be a problem right but at the
end of the day that's that's going to be
the person who's going to make the diff
the decision like i don't have i don't
have that power to stop people from
doing what they want to do and what they
have to do i don't i don't so yes it
could potentially be a problem
all in all that's your girl's
responsibility that's that's
it okay cool so it's just but we'd very
we we'd be
like very flirty with each other only
because we haven't seen each other in a
while
and he had no idea about my relationship
and i never
disclosed with him that i was in a
relationship
now we're getting i think we can we
follow the problem okay all right now we
now now we're in shady territory come on
now
okay yeah all right let's let's listen
this is a no judgment zone by the way
i'm not judging i'm just no judge zone
no judge zone i just knew that me and
him were never gonna go anywhere
and i never see him often anyway but it
was always my intention
that if i ever stopped
messing with my boyfriend that i'd
always talk to him
okay now we're in full shady territory
you are bugging so i'm not gonna get
angry let me just chill
i'm not angry
it's okay you knew what you were doing
it's not like don't just
you know what bro it's not i'm not angry
at what she's saying
i'm angry at how she says it the
positioner is
so comfortable like this is just
acceptable
no this is it's not what that's not what
bothers me this
there's nothing but that bothers me it's
just that it's not the fact that she
says his opening
the fact that she's open about it you
want people to be honest well you're
gonna have to
deal with the fact that you're gonna
hear some pretty uncomfortable things no
i understand that but hold on
what what it's just the way she says it
she positions herself
in a way that hey i'm not a bad person
i'm not this
i'm not that but i'm not gonna say
good or bad action actions it's not even
you're being disingenuous
obviously it's it's just you know it's
which is fine it's not
it's not a man or woman thing it's a
person thing like don't even think that
we're trying to badge this person
because she's a woman or whatever we're
not
it's just what that person is saying the
way they position themselves
that's just what it is which is fine but
it feels like
it feels like it's the way you position
it it feels like she's
monkey branching meaning she got her
boyfriend
every time she's holding on to him right
but she knows there's another rope right
there that she can hang on to
and she's kind of swinging just getting
ready when you monkey branch right you
already have
one and you hold on to the next one so
you got two right moving on
but even though at one point i did give
him my number
i knew that the text messages would only
be just that
just text messages i knew i would never
link him i knew i would never let him
on dates or anything like that because
i'm in a relationship and if you're
happy in that relationship
no one can't come in there and
mess it up now in another instance when
you're not
happy i think that you're gonna find any
reason
for someone else to come in the picture
and
take you from the unhappy relationship
that you're in
i can't understand what you're saying
but thank you
you know what it makes it sound like
it's because she's not she's not
responsible of the action that's
happening that's my problem
yeah i know but that's that's a lot yeah
that's the other people
taking no no you're not you you're
leaving yeah i know
that's what i told you yeah she's
positioning yourself
yeah to you know what i mean is the
position it's not what she's saying i
don't care
it's how she says it it's what it's not
what she did
she's how she's trying to position it
yeah she's positioning like no it's not
me it was never me
it was never me because it was biology
you're here it was never that i did
monkey branch the rope was just there
there it was calling me the guillotine
didn't cut marie antoinette's throat
the throat got in the way of the blade
you know what i mean like
i didn't shoot you you just happened to
be standing in my way you were not
halfway through
you were in the pathway can you just
come on girl just move
out of the hey listen if i shoot i shoot
if you happen to be in the path of the
bullet i mean move
you know that's that's what it that all
right let's give it a shot
so another example i was with the same
guy
and we were going through a bit of a
rough patch um
we were basically in the decline of our
relationship
and at the same time i met this one guy
and he kind of kept appearing in my life
i would see he kept appearing in this
he like i caught you know what i mean it
gets deeper and deeper
this is what happens when girls say they
got male friends and [ __ ] just like
so how's your relationship and every six
months just like the ghost of the bitter
there's a ghost of a thirsty [ __ ] so
how's your relationship
if you ever want to talk i'm out here
we're just friends are we
i'm here if you need me you're getting
good at this
you're getting good at it but you just
have to
we kind of ended up working in the same
company
so we were around each other a lot of
the time
and he took me on dates but it was very
casual
stop collaborate and listen
stop he kept appearing we were around
each other a lot
he took me on dates because you know you
didn't take him on dates right so it's
not there's no
oh oh hello
you find me a giant red flag because
that's all i see right now
this whole video is a red flag yeah
he would just be like let's go out here
like let's do this or whatever
and you know obviously those are dates
and i still willingly
went out with him all those times not
really giving a [ __ ] that i had a
boyfriend because
he was such a great energy i loved being
around him
oh oh okay this is that jada pinkett
this is that jada pickett you were an
entanglement is that what happened
because you needed to feel good so you
needed to it was not
august but you needed to feel good about
you needed to make yourself you were so
because it's been
so long well so long well
since i felt good so so
so so what what happened with august
i told you well i had an
entanglement with our kids that's what
this
is that is if you didn't if you wanted
to know what had happened before
the william and and jada situation [ __ ]
this is the beginning of it this what it
is
take it crazy stuff they got the same
haircut
that's what i was like you know how
white people got the carrying arrow cut
the jada haircut you know how this is
the entanglement area
you know how boy's always got the no
hair on the side here on the top
well yeah i've got this haircut right
here yeah
so jada pinkett smith so what are we
doing today miss
uh i don't know i feel disingenuous oh i
know exactly what to get you
snip snip snip snip
i loved how like happy i was
around him and my boyfriend at the time
was just blessed
and our relationship was just sucky so
i mean at one point i did realize
what i was doing was wrong so i kind of
had to end that relationship that
friendship that i had with him
to respect my relationship because i was
disrespectful to my relationship for all
that time that i was hanging out with
him
but i mean that was just me i feel like
for anyone
they could have let that situation
escalate they could have
i already went on dates but someone
could could have let it go as far as to
sleep with that person well she knows at
the end she like i'm
she knows she says it so it's just it is
what it is
like i said there's nothing i can do
that
it's going to change anything or
whatever what not you know i mean it's
like
there's nothing going on dates that's
crazy
but what do i know oh she wants to have
fun
she wants to have you know she wants to
have that spark to me
it's been so long to me whether you or
you went on dates it's the same
really yeah for sure just based off of
how the reward system works between men
and women
she got what she wanted out of that
dynamic do you know what i'm saying
it's not so much the dates it's what you
got out of it
yeah and the position that you put
yourself up and then i'm glad that the
answer was saying you know yeah i was
being this and that so
it is what it is yeah i i don't disagree
with you on that but at the end of the
day
even when she looks back to in hindsight
some of the language is a little bit odd
but
yeah if if i was on a relationship with
a girl she was going on dates with
another dude
that she has romantic feeling towards
even if they don't bang
it'll matter to me you still violated
the relationship you violated the
boundaries that we made clear to each
other to talk with so
whether you banged or escalated that to
me i'll be honest with you to me
i actually think it's worse
if you would have banged the dude and
not gone on dates it would have been
worse no no it would have been better
if she would have just banged the dude
knock on on dates okay yeah i see what
you're saying i agree
yeah because then there's not that
buildup in that yeah yeah i see what
you're saying yeah i see what you're
saying yeah
that's just me though but um it's all
bad to me
it's still violation of the trust i
think i think ideally
if you're if you're going through a
situation like that that has to be
something you communicate with your
partner
while having integrity towards yourself
because forget disrespecting your
partner you're also disrespecting
yourself
you made a commitment that has to mean
something if you violate that commitment
it reflects more on you than it does on
your partner's feelings because that
says something about
your character definitely so to me
that's that that's the
disappointing part uh more than anything
in those kind of situations it's like
damn
i let myself down
and you have to work really hard to come
back from that i got that right
yeah so that's pretty much what i
thought anything else you took away no
no
that's just that's what i said the way
is the positioning
is the position if you do something you
know but it happens a lot bro
like you know when people leave a
relationship and they already have
somebody else lined up and
they've been talking to them for weeks
oh no we're just friends and then two
weeks later they're in the relationship
on facebook
you lying i don't know it's a it's a way
where you
when you get out of a relationship it's
good to spend time alone
it's good to spend time alone it's just
good to just be a
things no no and a ladies i'm gonna tell
you oh
there's a lot of dudes waiting in the
cut oh no
a lot of dudes they know our friends
lurking
wait doesn't mean you guys are talking
works doesn't mean anything he's just
buying his time they're waiting for the
long game have you seen this jogger
and encounter a cougar no there was a
jogger that
anything there was a bunch of joggers
you know yeah and then
they say wrong wrong time wrong place
wrong time
no it was right place wrong time that's
that that's
the cougars environment you know yeah
you go run in the woods
you know what i mean anyways whatever
that's beside the point all right cool
there's a cougar there and he was just
talking the guy
for six minutes and god was filming
that's what's happening there's some
guys that lurkers just wait wait
waiting to pounce waiting and you like
they go on facebook and it's written
change change relationships that is oh
hey girl and then they slide in they
know yeah they know i've done my own
version of that except i didn't i didn't
pretend it was a friendship i said girl
you know where i'm at if you single you
can highlight oh but we can be friends
no no no because i know that's not what
this is
i know that's not what this is for me
personally and i know a lot of dudes who
don't want to admit that and want to get
real close me i'm like hey
won't you single holla at me maybe
you know maybe even then i've said no a
couple times because girls are like
ready and eager
when you break up yesterday i'm like
[ __ ] i know rebound like you said slow
it down
you said no and it just made me think of
that girl on instagram my jimbo
who that yeah it's a girl it's a
refrigerating girl talking to the camera
all the time
you want to be friends with me no i'm
not
i'm not you want to be friends i don't i
just wanna
you want to be friends with me bro no no
i'll pass yeah join three by this
that's an overview
i have no problems on that and girls get
mad oh uh you just want me for my no i
don't
but i also don't want to pretend like
this is a friendship that's not the way
i see you i have romantic feelings
towards you
so it would be a lie to not have that so
that's just me personally
but hey maybe i'm wrong maybe i don't
know what i'm talking about but if
anyone
has social media you're all seeing what
i'm talking about girl ends up single
right and then one week later she's
dating her her so-called best friend
come on b
what you think i just started a week ago
about it we're gonna go
you you think that started just a week
ago
be honest if it was your relationship
and your girl or your boyfriend was
dating the girl that he called the best
friend throughout the whole thing
you wouldn't find that super sus that
super success
you got to float we got to get voted out
this is among us you i'll be i'm i'm
pressing the button
i'm running i'm not leaving the table
okay
we're going out black this [ __ ] over
here
get him out of here so y'all know we
want to hear your thoughts leave it in
the comments below
man